- [Instructor] A sociologist suspects
that men are more likely to have received
a ticket for speeding than women are.
The sociologist wants to sample people
and create a two-sample Z interval,
in other videos we
introduced what that idea is,
to estimate the difference
between the proportion of men
who have received a speeding ticket
and the proportion of women
who have received a speeding ticket.
Which of the following are conditions
for this type of interval?
Choose all answers that apply.
So, like always pause this video
and see if you can answer it on your own.
All righty, let's review our
conditions for inference.
So, you have your random condition
and these are the same ones
that we have talked about
when we were dealing with one sample
but now we just have to make sure
that it applies to both samples,
that both samples we feel
good are randomly selected.
The second one is the normal condition
and this is to feel good
that the sampling distribution
of the sample proportion
for each of the samples is roughly normal
and so, what you have to do
is you take the sample size
of the first sample times
the sample proportion
of the first sample
and that needs to be
greater than or equal to 10.
You take the sample
size of the first sample
times one minus the sample
proportion of the first sample,
that should also be greater
than or equal to 10.
Another way to think about it
is your best sense of the
expected number of successes
and failures should be
greater than or equal to 10
and then you do this
with the second sample.
So, the sample size of the second sample,
these don't have to be the same,
times the sample proportion
of the second sample
should be greater than
or equal to 10 as well
and the sample size of the
second sample times one
minus the sample proportion
of the second sample,
that needs to be greater
than or equal to 10.
This is has to and,
all of this needs to be true
and then the final one is
the independence condition.
And we meet that if
individual observations
in these samples are done with replacement
or if even they're not
done with replacement
but if the samples are no more
that 10% of the population
then we meet the independence condition
and once again, you've seen this before,
we're now just doing it with two samples.
So, let's see.
Which of the following are conditions
for this type of interval?
So, the samples both
include at least 10 people
who have received a speeding ticket
and at least 10 people who haven't.
Yeah, that's right.
This is, you could view
this as the expected number
of people who have
received a speeding ticket
and this is the expected number of people
who haven't received a speeding ticket
or an estimate of the expected number
because we're using the sample proportion
instead of the true proportion.
So, these need to be
greater than or equal to 10
in both samples.
So, this is absolutely true.
The people in each sample
can be considered independent.
Yeah, we have that independence condition.
Either they're sampled with replacement
or we are sampling no more
than 10% of the population,
so this is important.
And then last but not least
they take separate random samples
of men and women.
Yeah, that's the random
condition right over here.
So, they have all three
of them right over here.
We have our normal condition,
our independent condition
and our random condition.
Let's do another example.
A biologist is studying a certain disease
affecting oak tress in a forest.
They are curious if there's a difference
in the proportion of trees
that are infected in the
North and South sections
of the forest.
They want to take a sample of trees
from each section
and do a two-sample Z test
to test their hypotheses.
Which of the following are conditions
for this type of test?
So, pause the video again
and see if you can answer this.
Okay, so we've already
reviewed our conditions
for inference, so let's see which of these
are the actual conditions for inference.
So, both samples include at 30 trees.
So, this might have been tempting
because this 30 number shows up
when we're thinking about conditions
for inference when
we're dealing with means
but this does not come up
when we're dealing with proportions.
Both samples do not need
to include at 30 trees,
so this would not be one of our choices.
They sample an equal number of tress
from each region of the forest.
This is a very common misconception
that when you're doing a two-sample Z test
or when you're doing a
two-sample Z interval
or confidence interval
that both samples have to
have the same sample size
but that is actually not the case.
So, we can rule that one out.
They observe at least 10 trees
with the disease
and at least 10 trees without the disease
in each sample.
Yes, this is the normal condition
that we just looked at,
so this would be our only
choice and we're done.